this is literally the worst weekend ever
we're never gonna get into comic-con
least you got a good haircut I got the
dog haircuts I start high school on
Monday with a dog haircut
I wanted my best friend's to have the
best weekend ever before we started high
school on Monday
but the best memories they never come
from what you plan they come from how
terribly that plan goes wrong distract
my house walk my dog you put my whole
life in lit on fire how are we gonna
survive high school and we can't even
survive this weekend I'm sorry if you
think I got cool I said some things I
wish I didn't say it's over nothing is
over until we decide it is only going
gets tough the tough get going don't
worry I plan I hate it when you say that
everything changed high school you like
luxuries no sometimes you just have to
be bold and fly for
don't make us get any worse he will jump
from 12
cholesterol
The Situation's the instrument but for
us when a crash proof
right you said this had to be your most
fun weekend ever tada best weekend ever
why
you
you